what do you think makes you different
from the other screenwriters who have
come to hollywood
during the same time where you've been
able to make a career at this
and possibly they haven't i think
understanding the business
because i was in the business part of it
first and producing and just
knowing like how distribution works
knowing like what they you know how
how actors sell films and things like
that because it just you can kind of can
filter it through a different kind of
lens where it's like okay this is
what people are looking for because i've
been to afm i've been to cannes
i've been to you know sundance on the
business side of it
so you know you see all those posters
you see what kind of movies are trying
to put together and you also see how
many movies are being put together
you know it's like astronomical if you
go to afm how many films are
you know tens of thousands of them and
maybe you know a finite
number of those get made but you see a
recurring theme and you kind of
understand how these people work
you know and it just depends on on what
kind of like
you know level you're at to studio level
is completely different i'm talking more
about the indie world you know but
breaking into the studio world is very
difficult as well he said you have to
work your way up on that
so i think that gave me advantage that
was just understanding
um the business and i can also put
myself in the mindset of a producer
when i'm writing something and i know
okay the producer's not gonna like that
but they'll like this
so that helps where someone else may
have come out
but they had no prior film industry
experience
and so even though it's a very
personalized story
it just won't work because it doesn't
tick these different boxes
exactly and like who's going to be like
like we talk about the
the movie about your uncle who runs a
you know a pawn shop
you know what actor is dying to play
that part that can finance a film
and then that turns into a whole nother
conversation altogether because there's
so few actors at certain levels that can
finance a film that's the reason you see
so many bruce willis movies nick cage
movies
you know john travolta movies there's
not a big pool of people that can
justify
people spending five 10 20 million
dollars
so that's part understanding that's a
big part of it as well
how does genre factor in getting a movie
made well
this is a very important thing to
remember is that
the reason you see so many action films
on uh
netflix and things like that it's
because action films and thrillers
translate internationally if you want to
make a
comedy and it's a comedy about a bunch
of kids in new jersey
and and you know they're going through
their last summer before they graduate
high school and there's a bunch of jokes
about you know american kids in jersey
that's not going to translate in like
malaysia
they're not going to understand it so
those movies have no very little
international value
but now action and thrillers sci-fi and
horror
is like an international language that's
why you see so many of those films
because they can sell not only in
america but
all around the world and that's also
something you need to keep in mind
if you have this small intimate you know
film that you want to make about
the screenplay that's about you know
four sisters in ohio
and it's a comedy drama it's like you've
got a very
small audience for that so you know
that's why
producers don't like things like that
and that's why when you look you can see
so many of those action thrillers on
netflix because they make money
internationally
but what if it's in someone's heart i
don't mean to sound so cheesy but what
if it's
what if it's in someone's dna that they
just
want to make a coming-of-age story and
to them they have to get that story out
there
and they want to finish it well i mean
if
if you're a screenwriter like that
that's got that story i think you should
become a filmmaker
if it's that that story is like figure
out a way to make the ten 10 000
version of that or the 50 000 version of
it and make it
you know that's that's the thing is like
you've probably got a better chance of
like
cobbling together your friends and
making a decent movie of that
and maybe getting in some film festivals
getting noticed like that than just
sending your script out to people
so that's what i would suggest you know
now that takes money and resources but
if that's your passion project you know
spend a few years you know
putting together all those resources or
figure out a way to shoot it there's
you know there's great films that have
been made for ten thousand dollars
you know you just have to understand how
filmmaking works that's a whole nother
conversation altogether but
you can do it i think we've already
touched on this but
is it correct that you didn't get an
agent until you sold your first script i
had a manager
and then um when we sold the second
script
there was an article about the hollywood
reporter and then literally
that next morning there was like 10
agents called
now you don't always need to here's the
thing is agents are great
but they're not a magic bullet for your
career either you know they do things
for you and managers do too but you have
to do a lot on your own you have to meet
producers you have to get out there you
have to do things
um and i think actually part of that
what got the ball rolling on that
that film was was people really dug the
script but i think the reason we
got involved with those producers
because i'm forgetting some of this
stuff is a friend of mine who had worked
with me on a film that i had produced
who was a production coordinator was now
working for them as a development exec
and she was like you should check out
their script so it all kind of tied
together from one thing into another so
it's all about those relationships again
what was the title of the article don't
remember just it was one of those
generic sold
sold a script you know but back to the
agent manager thing it's like
you know they're great to have but they
they work
you know they only have so much
resources to give you you can't like
rely on them for everything
even if they care and they they take the
time to read but they have 20 other
clients so you have to like
really understand you know what
how to use them as well have a
relationship where because they their
bottom they have a bottom line you know
they have to make money too
so a lot of people think oh i just want
an agent manager but you have to
think what are you providing them are
you selling things do you have things
you can sell
you know are they going to take you on
as a client and build your career
so where are you in the process as well
what do you provide for them
and so when you got those calls the next
day how did you
know which person you wanted to go with
or
or even entertain going with you you
have you have meetings and you meet with
them
and then you kind of just decide you
know who's
who's the correct person you know based
on based on instinct and and also to
um yeah chemistry and and also the
manager will kind of push you in that
right direction too we had a manager at
the time
and they were like hey you know our
manager said i've got some other clients
with
with him and you know so it's all very
there's a lot of synergy there when you
got those calls and i'm assuming it
wasn't like you woke up and then
your phone's buzzing it's like one of
those no it's not like that hey jim this
is so you know so
but how did were you like this is
happening like i've i've made it
i mean it felt good to have an agent but
it felt good to have a manager too but
you quickly learned that like you know
you've got to do the work it's like okay
well you sold something
that you know they weren't part of so
they didn't get commission so they're
like what's next
you know and so it's like you've got to
get back on the treadmill and start like
figuring things out and doing things
you